now this is the delusion yeah okay like
maybe guys in the comments correct me if
I'm wrong I don't know maybe I don't
know what I'm talking about is this
beautiful this is corn this is corn like
you don't have to lead with your weight
there have been big celebrities that
none of us conservative media types go
after or care about because they don't
lead with their weight Adele I was
looking at Adele's pictures let's pull
up Adele's Instagram I was I was looking
and this is a woman with 54 million
followers okay so freaking talented she
lost the weight but I was looking at her
Instagram from when she was big nobody
talked about this picture nobody cared
everyone loves Adele and when I say when
I make one of the whales and the big
women I'm not talking about women that
don't lead with that we all have our
struggles in life right mine is sugar
addiction but there's a difference
between working on our struggles and
trying to improve and accepting them and
pushing them is a positive thing